When you love something you fight for it
we're the ones who changed everything
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
marvel shang chi trailer video they dropped a whole
bunch of new footage with that big marvel phase
4 trailer so we'll break it all down the iron man
easter eggs the connections to the iron man movies
in the mcu and how they're sort of rewriting some
of the origins of the mcu going back hundreds
and thousands of years if you're new to the
channel we're doing a new giveaway for disney
plus memberships all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your predictions for
the movie on the video so we'll talk about the new
footage then i'll talk about the iron man easter
eggs and connections the 10 rings of power and how
they're changing this version of the mandarin and
this version of shang qi obviously rewriting some
of their origin stories to fit within their
pre-existing mcu continuity without actually
retconning any of the pre-existing stuff they've
already done in the movies really important detail
about the movie i've actually been saying the name
shang chi but kevin feige in his big marvel phase
4 presentation and then Simu Liu the star of the
film who's playing shang chi actually said that
it's pronounced more like shang chi or chi we've
just wrapped production in australia on our film
shang chi and the legend of the ten rings because
everybody got weirded out when i tried to say
it the correct way a couple of videos ago
so we get a bunch of new scenes of him and
awkwafina's character katie being taken back to the
mandarin's headquarters this palace here is a very
fortress looking hidden city looking palace like
if we're talking about ancient chinese palaces the
real hidden city the way they've been hyping up
the mandarin like he's been here this whole time
ruling over everything from the shadows since the
birth of the mcu actually since before the birth
of the mcu the character that awkwafina is playing
as far as we know is just named katie we don't
know what her last name is really they haven't
told us she's just being pitched as this normal
girl that shang chi becomes best friends with
during the 10 years that he spends on his version
of rum springer like the mandarin tells him go
out and do whatever you want to have as much fun
as you want before he has to come home and start
working at the family business again so to speak
ruling over the 10 rings organization at
my side as it seems like his sister has
been doing for the past 10 years the way they
explain her character is that she just stayed
with their father continuing to be trained
so she's just as fearsome a fighter as he is
but the whole pitch of his character is that
he is supposed to be the world's best fighter
but when he has the 10 rings that's sort of like
the boss level upgrade that makes him top tier
a-list avengers powerful the way the 10 rings of
power work in the comics they treat them kind of
like infinity stones each with their own unique
powers and unique essences which i'll explain in a
second because it does get kind of complicated but
i think the mcu version of the 10 rings are going
to be a little bit different like they don't want
to just do another version of the infinity stones
but as far as the way they're pitching aquafina
during the movie i don't believe that unless
there's some big secret about her character that
she does not have special powers herself now the
funny thing is is they do have a version of fing
fang fume in the movie that they're calling the
great protector obviously looks very different
from comic book thing fang fume but i believe
that this great protector dragon is meant to be
the movie's version of that character and you
see all those tiny dragons flying around in this
epic battle scene at the temple here i believe
those are meant to be the movie's version of
the Makluans from the comics the ancient race
of space dragons that basically crashed land on
earth the funny thing about aquafina though is
that she was just in that movie riot in the last
dragon as a dragon she actually played a dragon
during that movie and now she's obviously in this
movie with a bunch of other dragons flying around
we also see a lot of flashbacks where it seems
like a younger version of the mandarin wearing
white is fighting this epic battle here against
the person in green who seems like they're also
connected to the mythology behind the ten rings
in the mcu because all the fight scenes we've seen
with him so far at least in the flashbacks are
of him trying to lay siege to this giant temple
so obviously that is probably connected to the
origin of the ten rings in the Makluans there is
a special mystical pet that comes with katie's
action figure that they're selling so at some
point she might pick this up during the movie but
they haven't explained what this creature is and
what role it serves during the film there's more
footage of him fighting death dealer in that big
high-rise fight scene with the helicopter there
that seems like it's before they get carted back
to the mandarin's temple there is a new scene of
katie driving that bmw through the streets of san
francisco in a chasing this will probably remind
you of the big chase scene from ant-man and the
wasp because that also took place in the streets
of san francisco i believe this is just taking
place in a different part of san francisco so
some of the characters from ant-man and the wasp
could cross over into this but the whole idea with
the great protector fing fang foom the dragons in
the movie the maculans and the ten rings of power
is that they're all meant to be connected so the
maculines are the ones who created the ten rings
of power that the mandarin uses fun connection to
the guardians of the galaxy movies so their home
planet the maculans is in the andromeda galaxy
which is where the events of most of the guardians
of the galaxy movies take place not including when
they're crossing over with avengers infinity war
and avengers end game in thor 4. the nine realms
in earth are all part of the milky way galaxy
eventually a group of them just got bored and
decided to leave the planet seeking excitement
elsewhere fing fang fume was the navigator of
that ship they wound up crash landing on earth and
that's basically the spaceship where you find the
mandarin's ten rings the ten rings themselves
are actually ten cylinders that are part of
the maculine's technology each one is meant to
contain the soul of a long dead legendary cosmic
warrior so each of the rings themselves is alive
the same way the infinity stones are alive they
have sentience when the mandarin touches them they
actually shrink in size and he's able to put them
on his fingers and wear them like rings so it's
a lot like iron man's nano infinity gauntlet it
just changes sizes depending on who's wearing it
when you see it here it's human size when you see
thanos trying to stick his giant sausages into it
it makes itself bigger so that it'll fit issues
that are taking the mythology in the mandarin's
origin story to vary game of thrones epic level
proportions within the mcu beyond what you saw in
the iron man comics but it seems pretty clear in
the movie that he's engaged in this long-term war
across many hundreds of years against this group
of monks all wearing red at this temple who seem
like they're connected to these smaller dragons
flying around who might be the maculans during the
movie you also see the giant stone lions that have
come to life they're meant to be the traditional
stone lines that you see around chinese temples
mythologically they're supposed to serve as temple
guardians so just the limited footage that we've
seen so far this implies that the mandarin
is raiding this temple for some reason and
they're defending it against his army but both in
ancient history like a really old fight here with
them wearing this very classical looking armor
in another big battle in present day where you
see shang chi actually fighting amongst them
it seems like whatever this war is that he's
engaged in with these monks is the reason why he
compels shang chi to come home like this is the
grand purpose that i've trained you for the big
connection to iron man so first off you may have
seen they've released all those action figures but
they're bundling a lot of iron man ai figures with
the shang chi action figures release i don't think
that means we're gonna see ai version of iron
man show up during the movie but i do think that
they'll be using iron man's history in the mcu in
the iron man movies his connection to the 10 rings
organization starting that first iron man movie to
sort of weave in with the real mandarins backstory
in the mcu and obviously like all the other marvel
phase four movies build on how everything is
affected by the infinity gauntlet snap and
then the next two snaps during avengers end game
and obviously there's the trevor connection and
aim with aldrich killian remember killian called
himself the real mandarin at the end of the movie
and he had those weird dragon tattoos all over his
body what they typically done with the last couple
big marvel movies like avengers infinity war
avengers end game is find ways of weaving in new
story to make older movies seem even better they
can do the same thing with the events of iron man
3 trevor and aldrich killian pretending to be
the fake mandarin i don't think that they need
to include any big flashback scenes from any of
the iron man movies or anything like that i think
those will mostly be references and easter
eggs that they weave in hopefully they'll
also be some clever reference to trevor to even
if he doesn't actually appear during the film
but that would be a funny post-credits scene but
because i didn't talk about the titles in my other
video they obviously revealed the title of black
panther 2 is wakanda forever very apropos i will
do a separate black panther 2 video at some point
because they will be filming the movie pretty soon
the title of captain marvel 2 is going to be the
marvels plural because of miss marvel kamala khan
and it's a clever reference to monica rambo's
character who was actually the first female
version of captain marvel before carol danvers
in the comics i'm also kind of hoping that the
title is a reference to the blue marvel making
his debut in the movie too there was a casting
notice for someone that sounded kind of like
him they finally reveal guardians of the galaxy
3 is coming out may 5th 2023 i love the volume
graphics slider because it's volume 3 like the
volume readout on a tape deck registering playback
and even though they don't list a release date for
the fantastic four movie it's probably coming out
right after guardians of the galaxy 3 in july 2023
i'll do a separate fantastic four video at some
point when we learn some more about that movie
there'll be a lot of easter eggs in the marvel
phase 4 movies helping set up some of those brand
new characters along with new mutant characters
too but the x-men stuff is a little further off
than the fantastic four one of the reasons
why fantastic four is coming first is because
they've really never had a great movie but also
too because i believe galactus will be like the
quote-unquote next big thing like the next big
infinity saga level event that they're building
up to and that comes from the fantastic four
but if you spotted any new easter eggs in the
trailer that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments and i'll
do more trailer videos for the movie as we get
new footage there'll be a lot of big marvel stuff
happening while loki episodes are dropping i just
did a bunch of new loki videos you can click here
for that new trailer and you can click here for
my full eternals trailer video too in that marvel
phase 4 trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!